questa è la peggior squadra che io abbia
mai allenato nella mia vita
come potete intuire dalle immagini però
voglio parlarvi di loro perché da questa
squadra io ho ricevuto la più importante
lezione su come per raggiungere
espressioni di performance di
trasformazione del proprio talento
il risultato servano abilità tecniche ma
soprattutto serve la capacità di
sentirsi parte di una visione che serva
una parola magica che la parola
atteggiamento di questa idea di questo
concetto sul fatto che come dire dal
punto di vista tecnico quando noi siamo
costretti e concentrati su l'esclusivo
compito che ci viene assegnato cioè il
nostro bullone da abitare già un genio
dell'umanità come charlie chaplin
insegnava che il rischio è quello di
essere inghiottiti da quello che stiamo
facendo lì perdere la visione il disegno
collettivo il compito per cui noi stiamo
facendo quello che stiamo facendo e
nonostante poi magari ci sia la
possibilità qualcuno ci dia una mano ci
riporti fuori da questo meccanismo che
si è impossessato di noi che ci ha
catturato nei suoi ingranaggi
se noi da questa esperienza non
impariamo da quello che è successo non
abbiamo giovamento
rischiamo come qui sta per succedere di
commettere qualche errore anche
simpatico e banale come quello che
charlie chaplin stato al falchi
allora la la tecnica non è tutto
la tecnica non è tutto è la prima storia
che vi voglio raccontare quella di un
atleta che ci insegna anche la tecnica
non è tutto si chiama si chiamava emil
zatopek lui è uno degli atleti che
ancora possiede un record che
probabilmente non sarà mai battuto nella
sua dello sport siamo ai giochi olimpici
di helsinki nel 1952 e quest'atleta
grande fondista e maratoneta vince nella
stessa edizione dei giochi olimpici tre
gare i 5.000 metri i 10.000 metri e la
maratona tutto ciò avviene in pochi
giorni dalla prima all ultima di queste
tre gare impresa che rimarrà
probabimente imbattibile oggi una
specializzazione dei maratoneti fa sì
che difficilmente possono essere
competitivi nelle gare più di più breve
distanza
voglio vedere insieme a voi il finale di
una di queste tre medaglie i 5.000 metri
e mezzato perché questo atleta che
vedete in questo momento in testa
mancano 300 metri alla fine mi ha
raggiunto e superato da due atleti in
tedesco britannico che hanno una tecnica
di corsa perfetta guardate lui come
formale scomposto la testa che ciondola
alle spalle che vanno per conto loro
viene lasciato siamo ai 250 metri la
gara sta arrivando all'ultima curva via
in quarta posizione qui sembra che sia
destinato ad essere tagliato fuori
ma è proprio in questo momento qui ai
200 all'ultima curva che succede
qualcosa di straordinario
salto pecca riparte uno di quei due che
avevano una tecnica perfetta addirittura
cade e lui guardate come brutto
nell'esecuzione tecnica del gesto la
testa che ciondola la lingua di fuori
tagli al traguardo lui di se stesso
diceva una cosa geniale
non ho talento a sufficienza per correre
forte e sorridere contemporaneamente è
meraviglioso ma taglia il traguardo non
vincendo una gara una bella gara una
gara importante
iniziando un effetto domino che lo
porterà a siglare un record ripeto
probabilmente imbattibile nella storia
dello sport
proviamo approfondire qualche cosa che
riguarda questa leggendaria figura dello
sport per esempio la sua il suo metodo
di allenamento
questi sono le scarpe che lui utilizzava
per allenarsi inventando un metodo che
fino al suo arrivo all'atletica non
esisteva qui indossava questi stivali
pesantissimi cecoslovacco per fare delle
ripetute nella neve a sfinimento con un
sistema di sovraccarico molto moderno
per i tempi si chiamava dana nel suo
sistema di sovraccarico era la moglie
giavellottista anche lei olimpionica che
si metteva sulle spalle e con la moglie
sulle spalle con questi stivali
pesantissimi faceva le ripetute nanev e
un po alla rocky balboa inventando un
metodo che non esisteva che oggi si
chiama interval training utilizzatissimo
da tutti
un altro grande campione che ci ha
insegnato che come diceva lui stesso i
grandi atleti grandi campioni non si
creano nelle palestre ma sì che noi in
virtù del loro sogno della loro visione
e dicevamo a me delle mohammed al inc
ricordiamo anche perché purtroppo è
scomparso pochi pochi giorni fa conta la
tecnica conta l'abilità ma conta la
volontà e muhammad ali diceva la volontà
conta più dell'abilità perché ci
ispiriamo da questi grandi momenti di
sport perchè questi grandi campioni sono
capaci di ispirarci e di tracciare una
strada che noi possiamo seguire per i
nostri obiettivi e per esprimere la
nostra performance proviamo a rispondere
a questa domanda grazie a uno che di
sport
come dire non praticava lo sport ne era
appassionato ha scritto dei libri
bellissimi sulla boxe per esempio è
stato un grandissimo romanzi a del
sudamericano si chiamava julio cortázar
che diceva della letteratura dei libri
una cosa molto bella che poi si può
riapplicare nel mondo dello sport diceva
è curioso che ai ricchi ai borghesi
piacciano i libri e romanzi che
raccontano le storie della povera gente
perché diceva cortázar loro non hanno
quella prospettiva sulla vita e leggerla
legge nelle difficoltà nei libri nei
romanzi e il loro modo per soddisfare
una curiosità
viceversa dice cortázar alla povera
gente piacciono i libri romanzi che
raccontano direi di principi di castelli
di cavalieri per la stessa ragione loro
non hanno quella prospettiva sulla vita
e leggere i romanzi che parlano di
questi sogni e il loro modo per imparare
a inseguirli e sognarli pensate se
questa stessa immagine questa stessa
meta franosi può riapplicare nel mondo
dello sport i grandi campioni quelli che
ci ispirano sono esattamente coloro che
sono capaci di farci sognare la
magnitudine di un campione è
proporzionale alla sua capacità di farci
sognare come queste romanticissime
immagini circolate in rete ci ricordano
è un grande campione è un po per lo
sport come dire la stessa funzione di
quella del capolavoro nel mondo
dell'arte
il capolavoro succede ogni giorno nei
musei di tutto il mondo non ci sono
persone completamente diverse fra di
loro per genere per livello culturale
per interesse per conoscenza di
quell'artista che si trovano
magneticamente catturate da qualche cosa
il capolavoro che è lui che sta parlando
un linguaggio universale a loro che lo
guardano ci sono dei capolavori che sono
capaci di cambiare il punto di vista la
prospettiva è lo sguardo dell'artista
che si impossessa di noi un buon romanzo
un buon libro
noi lo gestiamo il capolavoro prende
possesso di noi ci costringe a cambiare
il nostro punto di vista è quasi
che dire sulla scia della teoria dei
neuroni a specchio tira fuori il
capolavoro che che è in noi ci sono dei
capolavori peraltro nel mondo dell'arte
che sono facilmente riconoscibili
basta entrare a roma nella cappella
sistina non bisogna essere esperti e
conoscere nel dettaglio la vita di
michelangelo e sufficienza alzare lo
sguardo e guardare il soffitto le pareti
e immediatamente si ha la percezione di
essere di fronte a un capolavoro
assoluto dell'umanità
ci sono però dei capolavori della storia
dell'arte che hanno bisogno di una
storia per essere definiti come tali
mi piace raccontare di questo capolavoro
di questo artista che ha creato un
capolavoro che ha cambiato un paradigma
si chiamava william turner era un
pittore romantico un bravissimo
paesaggista non un bravissimo il più
bravo il numero uno era colui che era
riconosciuto da tutti i suoi
contemporanei come quello più capace di
replicare sulla tela lui era un pittore
quello che il romanticismo chiedeva i
suoi artisti ai suoi scultore i suoi
poeti cioè la forza e l'impatto della
natura sull'uomo
lui era esperto in tempeste marine
dipingeva delle tempeste maniere
meravigliosamente belle con una tecnica
estremamente raffinata tutti gli
riconoscevano questa leadership ma non è
questo il motivo per cui questo artista
è passato alla storia dell'arte e ci è
passato per un suo insight per una sua
capacità di intuire un cambiamento
fondamentale lui si rese conto sapeva di
essere il più bravo di aver la tecnica
migliore ma siena secondo di eseguire
sulle sue tele
lo stesso gesto che facevano tutti gli
altri cioè di rappresentare la tempesta
vista dalla spiaggia allora racconta la
biografia di william turner che molto
romanticamente chiese al proprietario di
un vascello di essere accompagnato in
mare aperto mentre c'era la tempesta si
fece nel legare all'albero maestro di
questa nave perché voleva sentire su di
sé il freddo la pioggia sfalzati e la
pelle e al ritorno da questa esperienza
lo stesso artista incominciò dipingere
dei quadri come questo che io non sono
un critico d'arte ma converrete con me
che confrontate queste due tele
immaginiamo due cose la prima la
rinuncia
a quella tecnica che aveva fatto
diventare quell'artista al numero uno ma
il motivo per cui lui passa alla storia
e nella tela di destra lui cambia un
paradigma incomincia a fertilizzare
un'idea che succederà anni dopo alcuni
anni dopo la sua morte tra l'altro
succederà in francia che è
l'impressionismo ha cambiato un
paradigma rinunciando alla tecnica se
proviamo a immaginare il percorso che vi
ho brevemente raccontato di gestazione
di un capolavoro nel mondo dello sport
anche il mondo dello sport sono dei
capolavori di bellezza assoluta
basta guardarli per rendersi conto che
quella atleta quella squadra ha
realizzato un'impresa meravigliosa ci
sono i capolavori alle cui spalle invece
c'è una storia o dei capolavori che
cambiano una storia come è successo in
questa occasione che cosa c'è di comune
però tanto in un artista quanto in uno
sportivo e nel suo percorso di
produzione di un capolavoro
credo che tutti saremmo d'accordo se vi
dicessi l'allenamento
certo la tecnica va allenata allora vi
aspetterete da un allenatore di una
interpretazione una definizione di
allenamento io vi faccio vedere la più
bella definizione allenamento che abbia
mai incontrato nella mia carriera che
non sa non è stata scritta o definita o
raccontata da uno sportivo
questo e antoine de saint exupéry colui
che ha scritto il piccolo principe che
ha scritto questa frase meravigliosa se
vuoi costruire una barca non insegnare
non radunare i tuoi uomini per insegnare
non una tecnica e come si fa a tagliar
legna ea gestire e impartire ordini loro
insegnano la nostalgia per il mare vasto
e infinito questa è la più bella
definizione che io conosca di
allenamento perchè allenare in qualunque
aspetto della nostra vita altro non è
che allenare al desiderio di e torniamo
a lampeggio squadra che abbia mai
allenato
non ha neanche un nome questa squadra
una squadra composta è fatta da detenuti
dell'ospedale psichiatrico giudiziario
di castiglione delle stiviere provincia
di mantova
io in quell'anno allenava montichiari in
serie a
fui coinvolto in questo progetto mi
chiesero per sei mesi di allenare questa
squadra un giorno a settimana il lunedì
pomeriggio perché ovviamente questa come
si fa in queste strutture si tentava di
dare una mano queste a queste persone
dalle storie individuali come
immaginerete tragiche ad avviare un
percorso verso la riabilitazione
io accettai con un'unica richiesta che
l'attività sportiva non venisse fatta
nella struttura dell'ospedale
psichiatrico giudiziario ma nel
palasport di montichiari un palasport di
serie a
bello come tutti palasport dove si
giocano le partite in serie a con i
palloni che usava la squadra di serie a
con la rete bella come quella che si
usava nelle partite con un allenatore
non perché io fossi particolarmente
bravo ma semplicemente facevo parte
della scenografia ero un allenatore di
serie a
l'idea era quella di passare dal buio
nella struttura dove questi detenuti
vivevano sei giorni alla settimana in
una condizione di luce che era quella
dell'eccellenza bene ci fu un risultato
oggettivo di questa esperienza che mi
venne restituito da dell'estate da dei
dati statistici del addetti insomma alla
parte sanitaria di questa struttura che
mi fecero vedere dei dati dei test
matematici che raccontavano come dopo
sei mesi di esperienza queste persone
questi ragazzi questi detenuti avessero
ridotto di una percentuale superiore al
50 per cento la quantità di psicofarmaci
che assumevano allora questa grande
lezione
questa grande lezione in realtà la
proviamo anche noi tutti i giorni e lo
stesso principio per il quale noi siamo
influenzati in maniera determinante
dalla bellezza che l'ambiente
dell'ambiente che ci circonda
se noi andiamo a lugano in svizzera non
ci viene neppure l'idea di buttare una
cartaccia per terra
viceversa ahimé in italia ci sono ancora
ci sono degli stadi dove ancora oggi ci
sono le gabbie che ospitano i tifosi
avversari
e voi sarete d'accordo che sia una
persona viene messa in una gabbia
significa che c'è qualcuno che la sta
autorizzando a comportarsi da animale
la bellezza di ciò che ci circonda
influisce sulla nostra capacità
prestativa se io potessi regalarmi una
formula tesa al raggiungimento della
high performance
togliete lo sport qualunque settore
quello del business quello dell'arte
quello della musica quello della scuola
come si può riuscire a trasformare il
talento in risultato il potenziale in
prestazione
immaginate una linea di divisione sopra
a dividendo due fattori che si
moltiplicano certo le abilità tecniche
servono ma vanno moltiplicate per delle
capacità emozionali e naturalmente
questi fattori si moltiplicano quindi al
decrescere di uno il crescere dell'altro
mantiene alto il risultato finale della
formula poi c'è una linea di divisione e
sotto c'è un divisore io non sono
esperto di matematica però avete sapete
bene anche voi che se li sottoscriviamo
un numero molto grande e il risultato
finale la formula decrescere il numero
ideale la scriverli sottodivisione per
mantenere migliori stato possibile della
formula è il numero uno
allora lì sotto io scrivo la parola
metodo immagino la parola metodo e
questo metodo 1 questo metodo facile
comprensibile facilmente applicabile
velocemente applicabile
io lo traduco in un'altra parola che non
parola chiave della parola atteggiamento
potrei raccontarvi che cosa io intendo
con la parola atteggiamento ma
preferisco farvelo vedere facendo
riferimento a un altro capolavoro dello
sport siamo ai giochi olimpici di los
angeles nel 1984 e questa molto
semplicemente la prima maratona olimpica
alle quali le donne possono partecipare
fino a quella precedente 1980 mosca le
donne si riteneva che non avessero la
possibilità fisica di correre quella
distanza la gara in realtà è già finita
da un po di tempo una giornata
clamorosamente calda difficilissima la
gara è finita nel senso che chi l'ha
vinta un'americana è già arrivata da
tempo al traguardo ma entra nello stadio
per fare l'ultimo giro di pista gli
ultimi 400 metri una ragazza svizzera
che in realtà fa distruttrice di sci ma
è lì a rappresentare il suo paese per
correre la maratona
entrando allo stadio olimpico e
concluderà la sua maratona in questa
maniera si stacca da un alone and weight
la top five del symphony forse
camuffandola
sì persistent reway due o forse tel
a breve su despres
quando sinsys non made of birth of oman
forza leonaro camping per fare
capolavori servono tecniche e volontà ma
la volontà è più importante della
tecnica scegliete persone e atletico sì
grazie